One of the most controversial areas
in this very controversial subject of
capital punishment has been the
admission of victim impact evidence,
a testimony and other evidence about
the impact of the crime on the victim,
the person who was killed as well
as on the survivors of the victim,
the family of the victim.
And uh,
the impact on the community.
Uh,
this kind of evidence was
admissible and non capital cases,
uh,
for some time,
when the death penalty was reinstated,
uh,
are often precense reports
that would be prepared.
And part of the pre sentence report
would say what the impact had been.
Uh,
these are both in homicide cases,
but also non homicide cases.
What the impact had been,
uh,
on the victims,
how much money they lost,
whether they suffered any injuries,
what their hospital bills were.
Uh,
that kind of evidence.
but the most states had not provided for
that kind of evidence in their capital
cases.
Uh,
but one of the exceptions
was was Maryland.
Uh,
the Supreme Court is going to say in 1987
that it's not admissible in a case out
of Maryland,
which was about the only or one of very
few states that was allowing a victim
impact evidence in the penalty
phase of capital cases.
Uh,
but then very shortly after that,
the court would reverse itself in,
in 1991.
So we'll look at both these decisions,
uh,
and some of the questions raised by the
admission a victim impact evidence that
the first case,
uh,
was,
John Booth case out of
Maryland booth versus Maryland.
Uh,
and a written victim impact statement was,
uh,
presented,
which had the,
uh,
outstanding personal characteristics,
of the victim was one of the things that
was presented that urban Bronstein 78
and his wife,
rose,
uh,
were robbed and murdered in
their West Baltimore home.
Uh,
the statement was read by the prosecutor,
uh,
that talked about their qualities.
Uh,
also talked about the
emotional and personal problems
that family members had as
a result of the crime.
For example,
their son,
uh,
suffered from depression
and had trouble sleeping.
Uh,
he was fearful for the
first time in his life.
Uh,
and he,
he characterized the crime by saying
that his parents were butchered,
like animals.
Uh,
the daughter,
uh,
suffered also from lack of
sleep and become withdrawn
and distrustful a and said
she could not forgive booth for
having committed this horrible crime.
Uh,
and then a granddaughter said that the
murderer had just completely ruined a
wedding in the family because,
uh,
it had happened,
right after,
uh,
the wedding had happened right
after this terrible crime.
Uh,
and she also said she received counseling
but gave up on it because she didn't
think anything would do her any good.
So very powerful evidence.
Now,
this was not presented through the
witnesses as it often is today.
Uh,
it was presented by the prosecutor reading
this statement that had been prepared
by a,
a pre sentence report writer,
uh,
the Supreme Court,
as I said,
the opinions and characterizations
by the family members as well,
uh,
was part of what the,
what was included in that statement.
Uh,
in the case Justice Powell rights for
a very close five to four majority,
uh,
in the opinion two types of victim
impact evidence that comes in.
Uh,
and the question is,
uh,
first of all,
relevance is the impact evidence relevant
to the decision that the jury makes
about imposing the license
life imprisonment without
possibility of parole or
the death tunneling.
Uh,
and Justice Powell,
uh,
expresses the concern,
that admitting ms kind of evidence
could result in imposing the death sins,
uh,
because of factors about which
the defendant did not know,
uh,
wasn't aware of things,
about the,
the victim of the case
if it was a stranger,
uh,
and,
this would,
uh,
bring irrelevant factors into
the sentencing decisions.
Uh,
and so he said this creates
an impermissible risk,
uh,
that capital punishment,
resulted,
uh,
was imposed in an arbitrary manner
and violated the eighth amendment.
Uh,
he also talked about the evidence being,
uh,
very hard to rebut a that you would end
up with a distracting the jury because
there would be a mini trial,
uh,
on the victim.
Uh,
and that should not be allowed as well.
with regard to the
second type of evidence,
the characterizations of the crimes,
uh,
justice Powell holes,
that they can serve no other purpose
except to inflame the jury and divert it
from deciding the case based upon
the relevant aggravating mitigating
circumstances about the crime
and about the defendant.
Um,
this draws a strong,
uh,
descent,
and we'll look at that because this is
ultimately going to be the prevailing
view of the court.
Justice White,
uh,
joined by Chief Justice Rehnquist and
justice O'Connor and Justice Scalia
dissent,
uh,
their first point point that
we see from time to time,
uh,
is the question of what's a
judicial question and what's
for the legislatures to
decide.
And they basically say there's nothing
in the eighth amendment to the United
States constitution that prohibits
Maryland's legislature from deciding that
juries can consider this kind of evidence,
uh,
that we hold a murder accountable
for the harm that was caused.
Uh,
of course gives,
justice has given a number of examples.
If a person shoots a and Mrs,
uh,
they're guilty of one crime.
If they have the same intent and
shoot and hit and kill a person,
uh,
there's a completely
different punishment for it.
Uh,
so the court says we do measure the
harm caused not just the intent of the
person,
not just the act of the person,
but what harm is caused.
Uh,
they also say that the
state has an interest in,
uh,
balancing out the mitigating
circumstances that they've now allowed the
defendant to put on
anything in mitigation.
And therefore the state should be able
to counter that with evidence about the
victims.
Uh,
and finally,
uh,
the difference,
one of the questions that
Justice Powell raises,
we'll,
some survivors are going
to be much more articulate,
much better able to describe their loss
and their loved one than other people.
Uh,
justice white's says for the dissenters,
uh,
this is true of all
kinds of evidence that,
that often,
uh,
witnesses,
some witnesses are better than
others and some prosecutions,
the prosecution witnesses are better
than they are in other prosecutions.
That's just the nature
of the court system.
Uh,
well,
uh,
the court is going to reverse itself a,
just a short time later,
they did affirm,
uh,
or excuse me,
reverse one other case,
gay.
There's versus South Carolina,
uh,
based upon booth.
Uh,
but now we see a change in
the members of the court.
Justice Powell,
who wrote booth retires from the court
and he's replaced by Justice Kennedy in
1987.
Uh,
the court reaffirms booth and gathers a
and justice white who descended in booth
joins the majority opinion,
just basically saying,
I'm bound by booth and therefore,
uh,
I'm,
I'm going to vote to reverse
in this particular case.
Uh,
but then Justice Brennan retires a and
he's replaced by Justice Souter in 1990.
Uh,
and no sooner had just as
sooner joined the court,
then the court grants search Harare,
uh,
in a case out of Tennessee,
purpose Tyrone pain versus
the state of Tennessee.
And now the court overrules booth,
uh,
six to three for basically
the same reasons,
uh,
that the dissenters expressed,
in booth versus Maryland.
Uh,
pain is a very,
uh,
terrible crime.
Uh,
the,
uh,
killed a mother and one of her children,
and the victim impact evidence was,
uh,
the mother of the victim
testifying about Nicholas,
the son of the victim,
how he has been affected by the loss
of his mother and by the loss of his
sister.
Uh,
and she testifies the grandmother of
Nicholas testifies that he cries for his
mother.
That he doesn't seem to understand
why she doesn't come home.
He's only three years old.
He cries for his sister,
Lacey.
He comes to her often and says,
where is lacy?
Uh,
I missed my lacy.
I'm worried about Lacey.
Uh,
and then the prosecutors
in the closing argument,
uh,
ask the jurors to do
something for Nicholas.
I say,
one of these days,
Nicholas is going to be old enough.
He's going to understand
what happened to his mother.
what happened to his sibling,
and he will want to know
that justice was done.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
basically bring home the
death penalty so that,
uh,
Nicholas where Mel,
that,
uh,
the Supreme Court at Tennessee upheld
this even though it appears to pretty
clearly violate a booth versus Maryland,
uh,
pain petitioned the Supreme
Court for review it granted it,
but not too rural for pain.
But to take this opportunity
to overrule a booth,
uh,
chief justice Rehnquist
rights for the court.
And as I said,
these,
this is going to be based
on the same reasons,
uh,
that the court,
the same reasons set out in the descents,
uh,
in,
in booth.
Uh,
the states may decide
there's no restriction in the
constitution on the states
deciding,
uh,
what evidence can be admitted and the
states can decide to show the harm caused
by the defendant.
Uh,
and also the states can
counter the mitigating
circumstances by showing what the
harm was to the victim.
In other words,
almost exactly what justice white had
said in dissent and booth is now the
opinion of the majority
of the Supreme Court.
Meaning this evidence
is going to be admitted.
Um,
justice O'Connor,
uh,
because a lot of people,
including the dissenters in this case,
Justice Marshall and,
uh,
particularly in just a
Stevens and Blackman,
uh,
express so much concern rights to sort of,
deal with that.
Uh,
she says,
state may decide that a jury before
imposing the death pony can provide,
let the jury know the
full extent of the harm,
uh,
including its impact on the
victim and the victim's family.
Uh,
and also that the jury
can have a quick glimpse.
She says,
of the life the petitioner chose to
extinguished to remind the jury that the
person whose life was taken,
uh,
was a human being.
Uh,
but you also says this
can't be too inflammatory.
If the,
if the evidence is too emotional,
if it's too inflammatory,
it could make the trial
a fundamentally unfair.
Uh,
there are other concurring opinions,
but,
uh,
basically the,
the six,
uh,
carry the day,
just as Marshall,
this was justice Marshall his last day,
uh,
sitting as a supreme court justice.
It was a very last setting of the term,
uh,
and he was not happy.
Uh,
he thundered,
uh,
in his,
descending opinion that power
not reason is the currency,
uh,
that underlies the
court's decision making.
He pointed out that since
booth had been decided,
nothing had changed
with regard to the law,
the only thing that had changed
was the composition of the court,
which I outlined just a few minutes ago.
Uh,
and that there was no reason that the
court should reverse itself and go back
and overrule a booth versus Maryland.
Uh,
justice Stevens also descendant
joined by Justice Blackmun.
Um,
and he said,
in our law,
the prosecutor has never been allowed,
uh,
to introduce,
evidence that went beyond the guilt in
the moral blame worthiness or culpability
of the person on trial.
He suggest that this victim
impact evidence serves no
other purpose except to,
um,
uh,
weigh in favor of the death penalty
without really being relevant,
without providing the jury with
anything about either the crime or the,
uh,
the defendant,
that can be taken into account,
uh,
and that it invites the courts to decide
or juries to decide these cases based
upon emotion rather than reason.
Uh,
so,
uh,
strong dissents,
strong divisions in the court from the
time booth has decided until the time
pain is decided.
But once pain is decided,
the court pretty much leaves
this to the lower courts,
uh,
to decide what evidence is
going to be admitted or not.
Uh,
justice Stevens also points out a
that it can't be applied consistently,
uh,
in different cases because,
of,
uh,
circumstances that are unforeseen,
by,
by the defendant.
Uh,
basically,
uh,
there are a number of questions that are
remaining that remain after pain that
are being sorted out by state supreme
courts and to some extent by federal
courts.
Uh,
what evidence is admissible the court,
some courts have said that if you look
at the decisions and in pain and in booth
that while the court said
that the impact evidence,
the impact on the survivors
and the community,
uh,
and,
some indication of who the
person was that was killed,
is it miscible that the,
uh,
characterizations of the crime by the,
victim's families should not be allowed
to or their opinions about what sentence
should be imposed.
We see that in one of the cases
in the readings from Oklahoma,
uh,
that's really the,
the,
uh,
most courts have said that
characterizations of the crime,
uh,
and opinions about the evidences
is not going to be admitted.
But on the other hand,
uh,
and a federal death penalty case
battle versus United States,
uh,
guards at a federal penitentiary
where battle had murdered a guard,
uh,
testified,
with regard to what the impact was and
what the impact would be if he did not
receive the death Polly,
that it would be bad for morale.
Uh,
at the prison,
a United States Court of Appeals for
the 11th circuit upheld that testimony.
Um,
uh,
other,
concerns,
uh,
different classes of victims,
Justice Robert Benjamin has
descending opinion in Livingston,
uh,
was concerned,
about the fact that race and class would
be taken into account because already,
uh,
these may be factors that come into play
when a prosecutor decides whether to
seek the death penalty or whether to plea
bargain a case and resolve a case with
a plea bargain in a,
in a sentence less than death.
And now with the family
of the victim testifying,
uh,
justice been worries
that there's going to be,
uh,
again,
race and class factors
entering into this process.
Um,
when is the evidence too prejudicial,
uh,
when it's weighed against,
the probative value,
that is what it,
what it helps the jury understand
about the victim and about the impact.
Uh,
but when does this evidence
become prejudicial?
And of course,
this can be very emotional evidence.
Some courts,
like Georgia has said that
before this evidence is admitted,
uh,
there has to be hearing,
there has to be testimony and
some determination of how,
uh,
emotional and whether the
evidence might be prejudicial.
On the other hand,
in other states,
uh,
quite extensive,
evidence and characterizations
by family members.
And I'm a very emotional
testimony has been admitted,
uh,
and upheld by the courts there.
Um,
does the G,
how,
how does the jury consider,
uh,
the victim impact evidence?
Uh,
the jury,
uh,
it's told you way aggravating against
mitigating some of the jury instructions,
say the victim impact evidence
is not an aggravating factor.
Uh,
but then the question comes,
what is it?
Uh,
a lot of the jury instructions say that,
uh,
what it is is it tells you what the
harm done by the defendant was a,
and it's to be considered
for that purpose only,
but pretty clearly,
uh,
victim impact evidence is going to weigh
on the aggravating side of the scale,
uh,
when a jury is deciding whether
or not to impose a life or death.
So two things we would,
I would just say in closing
about victim impact evidence,
first of all,
what the Supreme Court has said is
that it never has to be admitted.
It's up to the states to decide.
So in a state that didn't have a law
providing for victim impact evidence,
uh,
that,
that evidence would not be admitted.
However,
what the court says is if a state chooses
to have a law allowing victim impact
evidence,
there's nothing in the constitution of
the United States that would prevent that
evidence from being considered a.
And then the only question
is whether or not a,
it's too prejudicial.
Justice Stevens,
uh,
and Kelly versus California express
some concern that a videotape which was
narrated a description of the
young woman's life who was killed,
narrated by her mother with very evocative
background music might go over the
line,
uh,
in terms of victim impact evidence.
Uh,
but,
uh,
that kind of evidence is,
and a lot of cases in
California and another parts,
uh,
of the country,
some states still don't
have victim impact evidence.
But once booth was decided,
as I said at the start,
uh,
before booth versus Maryland,
most states that had the death pony
did not admit victim impact evidence.
However,
after Payne versus Tennessee,
uh,
state's,
almost,
uh,
all the states that had the death penalty
pass laws allowing a victim impact
evidence.
And in many jurisdictions,
now it's a part of the
capital sentencing process.
The jury hears about
aggravating circumstances.
Here's about mitigating circumstances.
And also,
uh,
here's,
and the prosecution's case about the
impact of the crime on the victim,
who the victim was and how the family,
the survivors,
uh,
and the community were affected by it.
So this is very powerful evidence.
Uh,
court first says it's not miserable,
but ultimately,
uh,
it is,
and,
uh,
these questions remain,
and are being decided by,
as I said,
state and federal courts as we go forward.